Alright, so, here's a little bit of background on
this visualization. Napoleon invaded Russia in 1812, and suffered
a number of devastating losses. So Charles Minard created
this chart to describe the sheer amount of loss
that Napoleon caused in a simple, yet powerful graphic.
So if we start at the left of the
graphic, we are at the Polish Russian border near
the Neman River. And this flow line shows the size
of Napoleon's grand army 422,000 as they invaded Russia
of June of 1812. The width of this band indicates
the size of the army at each place of
the map. In September when the army finally reached Moscow,
it had dwindled to 100,000 men. The path of
Napoleon's retreat from Moscow is depicted by this lower, darker
band which is linked to a temperature scale which is
hanging down here. And also these dates that we see
at the bottom of the chart. It was incredibly
cold, and many froze on the march out of
Russia. This chart shows that the crossing of the
Berezina River was a disaster. And the army struggled back
to Poland with only 10,000 men remaining. Menard made
this plot to really highlight the huge amount of loss
that was caused by Napoleon's march on Russia. Look
at how many men died marching to and from Moscow.